it's dinner time time to add the pickles
thank you poland we always love to eat
with our hands it's from zimbabwe whoa
well it's secret
wow then added some wine so i'm making
fairy bread it looks incredible
boy that's good i feel like i'm gonna
make this a lot hi i'm hannah i'm the
rental case mom and it's that time again
we have done a few
weeks of cooking meals from around the
world it's become such a huge part of my
family huge part of my kids curriculum
and something that you seem to really
enjoy so we're going to do it again for
an entire week i'm going to cook a
different recipe from a different
country and the recipes will be
submitted by you so let's see where
we're going this week i can't wait this
has quickly become one of my favorite
things that we do together as a family
if you
is it yours too
this has quickly become one of my
favorite things to do as a family it's
really important in terms of getting a
full understanding of the dish
to understand the history so that's what
we always do with these dishes is we
cook the food and then we have a
conversation afterwards about the
history of the food the different
cultures the different traditions and
all sorts of fun facts about that
country now some of these recipes are
family recipes that i can't link but if
i have the link i will share in the
description and as always
go get a snack pause the video go get a
snack don't watch this on an empty
stomach you will be super hungry i'm so
excited tonight because i'm making thai
food it's very noisy in my house
i got an amazing recipe for pad craw pow
and it sounded incredible it's a minced
pork and holy basil stir-fry
and it's actually surprisingly simple
we're gonna do a couple hiccups so
lesson learned and i should have known
this going into it
if i'm ordering on amazon check the
dimensions so this recipe requires a
mortar and pestle to mash the chilies
and the garlic and i ordered one
and i got one for a doll so
i still think it's big enough to try um
but yeah this
isn't what i was expecting but it got
the job done it was tiny and a little
more time consuming but i eventually
minced the garlic and the chilies then
you saute with the minced pork you add
some seasonings and then at the very end
you throw in your holi basil my
followers said that it tastes really
good when it's served with a fried egg
so i served it with rice and a fried egg
and it looked incredible
yeah do you like your meat
baby yeah
daddy
wow this is amazing
[Music]
it's amazing that's amazing
this is going in our regular rotation
this meal is
fantastic and so easy and so
fancy i sent a picture to my follower
they said it looked really good and so
dipping my toes into cooking thai food
with this recipe was really awesome
because it was something i felt like i
could totally accomplish all right
today's meal is going to heavily rely
on these guys
pickle soup now something that sounds a
little different but ended up being
super delicious was pickle soup that we
made from poland so pickle soup is
essentially a potato soup that uses
grated pickles and pickle juice to give
it a really nice salty tang
okay so now i'm going to grate my
pickles
oh my gosh and henry will not stop
trolling you're pulling my pants off
henry time to add the pickle and juice
and then at the very end to make it a
little more creamy you temper some sour
cream which means you take a little of
the hot broth mix it with the sour cream
little by little so that the sour cream
doesn't curdle
yum looking good
when it was finally done and plated it
looked like a gorgeous potato soup i am
really excited to try it i love pickles
i taste the potatoes
amazing
i like it
thank you poland i know it sounds
odd because pickles are typically so
cold
the thought of serving them hot in the
soup might sound a little strange but
trust me when i say
it's so good well
it's creamy the pickles are not
overwhelming i will 100 be making this
again next up i decided to finally try
making one of the most requested dishes
of all time for this series
i tried my hand at biryani from pakistan
i scored my chicken and marinated it in
a yogurt and spice blend meanwhile i
soaked my rice and it's this interesting
way of par cooking it before you
actually cook it so it soaks for 30
minutes and gets a little tender and
then you cook it in the biryani got my
little pot of spices and we're gonna
toast them and that really brings out
the spice flavor and scent it really
makes them aromatic so after i cooked my
onions and my chicken and i added my
rice the recipe called for me to pour
water around the edges of the pot
and then one final cup in the middle and
i've never used that technique before i
think maybe
it helps the water
absorb more evenly through all the food
maybe if you're just pouring it in the
center it doesn't get to the sides
enough so i covered it and i cooked it
and then i
served it up
[Music]
is it hot
did you take too big of a bite
how many thumbs up
[Music]
two
good job
take a smaller bite oh my gosh what is
up with you guys
[Music]
whoa
i think i need to make it a gun i wasn't
expecting to nail this
and i didn't i think i
had a good first try
but i definitely need to try more
this is called biryani
i've had biryani this is really good
good morning everybody
excuse me i said good morning
so i'm making fairy bread
it looks so fun for kids it's just bread
with butter and sprinkles i have my
butter on my toast i'm just gonna
sprinkle this is sticking surprisingly
well for me it's really important that
we all try something new with each
recipe so we made vegemite toast as well
vegemite is a yeast extract it's kind of
like a thick
spread
very salty hard to describe i'm excited
to try this okay let's spread it around
we're gonna go light and then we can
always add more right some people are
very dramatic about vegemite and so i
was really curious to try it because to
me it's just an ingredient
no big
go ahead and give it a try let's see oh
my gosh i'm so excited wait give it a
try
[Music]
how is it the sprinkles out of water
flavor there's some butter
good i'm throwing my with some
sandwiches and it is really fun it's
something they're going to ask for in
the future for sure and it makes your
breakfast feel like a dessert when it's
not too deserty try the vegemite toast
hmm
[Music]
what does it taste like it's kind of
sour
and sweet oh
this is actually a really good amount of
vegemite you just need a little because
it's so flavorful this is fantastic so
thank you australia for upping our toast
game we have two new toasts that we get
to make and they're super delicious hi
hannah i'm retender from zimbabwe i
would love for you to try my dish of
peanut butter with rice it's known as
rice in italy in zimbabwe and it's a
very popular dish that most households
have and every sunday we used to have it
with my grandmother hope you enjoy bye
it's dinner time tonight's dish sounds
absolutely incredible it's from zimbabwe
i'm making peanut butter rice i'm also
pairing it with a chicken stew my
followers so kindly sent me two recipes
i'm going to bring this to a boil my
chicken garlic salt curry powder water
and i'm gonna boil this for two hours so
this is a rice that's mixed with
unsalted peanut butter you mix it at the
end and it gets really evenly coated and
gets this really creamy kind of tan
color to the rice now my follower also
told me that they typically eat this
dish with their hands they said i could
use a fork but we always love to eat
with our hands when the dish calls for
it um
oh henry's probably better than all of
us at eating with hands you do it every
day
wow
this is amazing
whoa
this rice is so good this recipe was
such a hit and truly if you haven't
tried peanut butter rice
go make it right now it is
so good thank you
and bad boy zimbabwe zimbabwe we're
gonna talk about zimbabwe tonight after
we're finished eating okay
zimbabwe is not a country in their
curriculum this far it's not a country
they had even heard of and so it's so
important as parents for us to bring
this awareness and do the teaching
ourselves and get our kids to have
appreciation and understanding of
countries that they might not be
learning about in school today we are
sticking to the united states actually
first time we've done a little bit
first time we've done this in an around
the world episode we're going to make a
u.s dish from rhode island we're making
wieners all the way
it's it sounds funny but it looks really
good and it's a very secret recipe
weiner's all the way
is a very specific very secretive
really like
cult following hot weiner everything is
really really specific that goes into it
from the buns to the wiener to the
toppings so it's a steamed bun
it's a hot wiener not a hot dog hot
wiener
oh my gosh i've been hanging out with my
kids too much
it's not a hot dog it's a hot wiener
and then it's topped by hot dog chili so
i steamed my buns i boiled my weenie
i like talking about this dish and then
i got to work on my chili
it's
well it's secret
i can't tell you what's in it
but it's a lot of seasonings and some of
them you might be surprised to find in a
hot dog chili i thought this recipe
would be pretty safe with the kids the
one wild card was it has to have onions
on it and that is one of the ingredients
that my kids get a little diva about oh
good
i love it
it's amazing guys
steaming the bun
it's so good this is better than ribs
it's better than ribs
ribs is your favorite food i guess we've
got a new favorite food in the house
looks good
hot dog beef
onions
[Music]
now that's too good hot dogs
i was also really nervous about this one
too because it is so particular i'm
even afraid to show you this because i'm
afraid i will get ripped to shreds by
people who are so obsessed with this
wiener like people get really touchy
about weiners
[Music]
there's no good way for me to talk about
this i'm gonna keep making this
especially if it's wyatt's favorite food
and hopefully one day we get to go to
rhode island and eat it there ourselves
all right i'm making pasta genovese
today and i'm really excited because
when i think of italian pasta sauce i
think of tomatoes and this one has no
tomatoes i started with a mirepoix which
is diced onions carrot and celery it's a
great starter for a lot of different
sauces then i added my meat added some
stock
let it simmer forever
then added some wine let that simmer
forever
one hour down
smells fantastic
so we're actually gonna be eating this
tomorrow because by the time it's
finished
it's going to be like 9 p.m i didn't
realize it's three hours of simmering
and then another hour and then i
realized i used wine in it so maybe not
the best idea for me to serve it to the
boys so matt and i just ended up eating
it ourselves
it's divine it is next level delicious
mmm the meat's really super tender
it's amazing it's good cold weather food
matt was obsessed with this sauce these
sauces are intense they're very very
refined and so i was really excited to
do a good job making that sauce now
looking back at this week it was really
amazing because i feel like i was
challenged a little bit more than other
weeks i feel like some of these dishes
were very clear starting points for me
to keep digging deeper and keep learning
and keep trying i think food is a
beautiful introduction
to learning more so i want to thank
everyone who submitted a recipe there
are only seven that i can use in the
video but i get hundreds of recipes and
i save all of them so i really
appreciate all the suggestions all of
the thought and care that goes into
sending these recipes it really has
helped my kids grow and transform in a
huge way so that's all for now i'm
hannah and if you've tried this with
your kids what did you make and how did
it go
and if you have any recipes from where
you live that you want me to try send
them my way even when i'm not filming i
still cook them and i try them and i so
appreciate them now if you'll please
excuse me i think it's time for me to
try making biryani again uh hopefully i
do better this time uh until next time
[Music]
you